- [Narrator] Sam Holtz was
12 years old when he won
ESPN's 2015 March Madness
Bracket Challenge.
- I had the best bracket
out of 11.57 million people.
- [Narrator] What if we told
you this bracketology prodigy
doesn't even watch college basketball?
- Before the tournament,
I really don't watch
any college basketball.
(upbeat synthesizer music)
- [Narrator] This time last year,
young Sammy was filling out
his winning NCAA tournament bracket
along with millions of other Americans.
Sam, what was your strategy for success?
- Well, I just filled out
who I think is gonna win.
- [Narrator] Was there
a science to your picks?
- No, it’s just pick whoever you want to win.
There's no science, just that simple.
- [Narrator] Hmm, maybe
Sammy's mom has an idea.
- I think he was lucky.
- [Narrator] All right,
let's take a closer look
at some of Sammy's predictions.
Why pick 11-seed UCLA to
make the Sweet Sixteen?
- [Sammy] Because I visited their campus
and I really liked their college.
- [Narrator] Or 7-seed Michigan State
to make the Final Four?
- Tom Izzo, the coach, is Italian
and I'm kind of Italian, too.
- [Narrator] Or Wisconsin to
upset then-undefeated Kentucky?
- [Sammy] It kinda gets boring to watch
the same team win and win every year,
and I didn't wanna see them do that.
- [Narrator] You must
really love basketball.
- [Sammy] I'm more of a
baseball/football guy.
Baseball is my main sport.
- [Narrator] How is this possible?
I mean, what are the chances
of filling out a perfect bracket?
We consulted bracket expert Mike Magazine.
- Somewhere in one in some
number of quintillions.
- [Narrator] Thanks, Professor Magazine.
Any advice for the millions of Americans
you'll probably beat out again this year?
- Just pick who you think is
gonna win and go with your gut.
- [Narrator] Remind us why
we should listen to you?
- 'Cause I won it last year.
(old-school hip-hop music)
- [Narrator] There you have it.
Pick the schools you've visited,
don't listen to the experts,
and don't watch any college basketball
and you too can reach the promised land,
just like Sammy Holtz.